houston aux états unis avec dave perkins
analyse politique partisan de donald
trump c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france une
enquête de l'attak du capitole avec ces
accusations maintenant de complicité
alors tout est anonyme
mais ce que ces accusations il vous
semble tout de même crédible
attendons maintenant le moment je ne le
pense pas j'ai étudié les vidéos je suis
les nouvelles concernant ce qu'on veut
le faire demain c'est sûr qu'ils
essayent de découvrir et ils connaissent
grâce à mon sens la réponse à toutes les
questions qu'ils posent et c'est
vraiment un spectacle pour la télévision
afin de retourner le public contre
donald trump gros il s'agit vraiment
d'un spectacle tour visée
professionnelle
afin d'influencer l'équilibré gauche
droite notamment parce que tu raiden ne
fait pas du tout un très bon travail et
et son taux de popularité est en chute
libre
je ne pense pas que ce qu'ils font on
aura un impact si ce n'est de retourner
le public contre donald trump et le
parti républicain si on vous suit bien
d'être perkins l'intérêt du magazine
rolling stone c'est de déstabiliser
donald trump en tout cas de l'enfoncer
entre guillemets si vous me pardonnez
cette expression ça voudrait dire que ce
n'est pas un magazine fiables selon vous
est pas et pas sérieux
magazine rolling stone serait être
sérieux mais
est un média qui est une part sérieux
puis après se veut un média de loisirs
puis redevient sérieux et donc quand il
n'a pas toujours le même niveau de
qualité
ila a produit deux harmonies kg et des
entretiens très intéressant ryad des
journalistes très talentueux
mais en l'occurrence ils sont maintenant
dans le camp démocrate et il souhaite la
même chose que le démocrate à dire qu'il
souhaite qu'on lui hier à donald trump
et au parti républicain en vue des
élections de mi mandat pour le poil et
en vue bien sûr des élections
présidentielles à venir car tout le
monde a déjà décidé que donald 30 jours
et un rôle majeur à nouveau donc je ne
fais pas confiance aux rolling stones
s'agissant de mener a été des enquêtes
politiques car sans aucun doute ils ont
un programme et on sait évidemment la
vie un clank est donc se poursuit ce
serait justement une des sources liées à
cette enquête
saleh serait donc à penser si c'était
vrai c'est faux selon vous en tout cas
que ce putsch entre guillemets 1 devant
le capitole il aurait été non pas
spontanée mais orchestrée en haut lieu
dé proche de donald trump ça aurait des
conséquences quand même assez grave sur
cette enquête et sur donald trump n'est
ce pas
[Musique]
déjà vu lors des trois années d'enquêté
concernant la collusion avec la
tous les jours les gens se présentaient
devant les caméras en dix ans nous avons
les preuves nous allons chasser
donateurs du pouvoir et trois ans plus
tard il n'avait pas de preuves et de
notre à la maison blanche
autant avoir des informations qui sont
en train de rassembler qui auront un
effet démonstrateur contre donald trump
mais il le disait déjà lors de la can
avec rien sur la russie et lorsque les
essais vont constituer
au regard de l'histoire récent parce que
je connais bien j'ai vraiment du mal à
croire qu'ils vont vraiment un récit
rapporté un compteur à donald trump et
aux républicains au contraire cela
pourrait même se retourner contre les
démocrates et renforcer encore donald
trump et le parti républicain la
commission spéciale s'est prononcé la
semaine dernière en faveur de poursuites
judiciaires en tout cas pour entrave au
travail du congrès contre l'ancien
conseiller de tram steve banane ça veut
dire que l'ancien président ait ciblé
mais aussi son entourage
de plus cela fait partie de leur
stratégie ils attaquent d'autres
personnes qui ont encore beaucoup à
perdre donald trump est encore très
riche identique bananes sont pas non
plus le cas d'autres personnes de son
cercle donc il a attaqué six de ces
personnes a caressé d'obtenir quelque
chose de
positif
ban a en outre
profité du soutien de donateurs
sur les liens contre la russie et le
style banane now africains qui auraient
pu faire du mal à donald rheault et n'a
encore aujourd'hui rien à dire qui
pourrait nuire à temps à 30
jours tant le gang dont un trente six
panneaux c'est au moins autant que moi
que les démocrates
des enquêtes vraiment bâclé il ne s'agit
que d'un spectacle télévisé fini temps à
changer l'opinion de la population
américaine
n'ont rien et un steward a le droit de
ne pas se présenter devant les tribunaux
de ne pas prêter serment
se retrouver face à eux leur donne un
simulacre de justice
essaye de le pousser au parjure en
disant que si je ne répète pas
exactement ce qu'il a dit auparavant
alors il s'agit d'un mensonge il
risquerait donc la prison pour parjure
si danone est trop intelligent pour
s'engager dans ce genre de piège et il
décide donc de ne pas répondre à cette
convocation et je pense pas qu'ils
réussiront à le forcer à
témoigner dernière question défaire
keynes quatre anciens collaborateurs de
l'ancien président aurait reçu un
courrier de l'avocat du de donald trump
en leur demandant de ne pas répondre aux
convocations de la commission denquête
pourquoi les empêcher de parler
finalement s'il ne se reproche rien ce
qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à les défendre
leur cause justement de vent devant les
enquêteurs
le parti démocratique est bien connu
pourtant la chose suivante faire prêter
serment à dos j'en ai ensuite l'heure de
poser de questions qui n'ont rien à voir
avec l'anglais mais qui sont liés à
d'autres choses qu'il souhaite savoir
cela force que ces personnes à dire la
vérité concernant des discussions
privées sur des questions de financement
levée de fonds
ce sont des choses qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément illégale ouais ouais pour que
l'on veut or forcément rendre public il
y a un droit à la vie
agréé par exemple
3,4 privé des conversations par exemple
répond certain monsieur cohen qui a
renoncé air surtout pas méconnaître
marche parfaitement le droit de demander
à ces gens
de témoigner
non de ces personnes qui ont témoigné et
peut-être qu'on ne saura jamais d'eux
qu'il s'agit car peut-être que
n'existent pas du tout en tout cas ce
que de notre indice et ne tombez pas
dans le piège qu'il tente pour vous
merci beaucoup d perkins nous avons
apporté votre opinion direct sur rt
france ce soir